que serait noël sans ces maisons parsemé
de guirlandes et autres décorations
scintillantes
certaines familles ont l'habitude de
revêtir leur demeure de belles parures
au plus grand bonheur des passants le
moyen de se mesurer au concours des plus
belles décorations de noël
une première à la verrière depuis
quelques années déjà on attendait ce
concours avec impatience et dès qu'on a
eu le flyer dans la boîte aux lettres on
a été super content que ce soit lancée
cette année sur la verrière et on s'est
empressé de répondre à la mairie et de
dire que c'était une super initiative
l'occasion de passer de bons moments
pour les familles à choisir les
différents ornements ainsi que leur
disposition ont commencé à installer
c'était marrant c'est qu'on y avait un
concours on a vu que ont il y avait le
concours du coup du coup on a commencé à
décorer tweet c'est surtout que ça
éclaire un petit peu dans tous les sens
et c'est aussi ça l'esprit de noël pour
nous à quelques kilomètres de là une
autre maison est prête et étincelante un
hobby de longue date devenu une habitude
même si aucun concours n'a lieu cette
année ça fait une dizaine d'années on a
commencé avec le concours des maisons
décorées de coignières et puis on s'est
pris au jeu tous les ans on remet ça
chaque année comme vous voyez il ya le
sapin il ya
l'élevage de rennes taillé dans du
polystyrène ya des guirlandes lumineuses
et boulay et puis on en ajoute une ou
deux tous les ans donc au début on est
parti avec une décoration très pauvres
qui au fil du temps brrr ça ça monte en
puissance
une mise en place qui a pris plusieurs
jours des petites touches personnelles
ont même été ajoutée pour parfaire le
décor les rênes le père noël et la luge
sont faits maison
ça met un peu d'animation dans le
quartier ce qui nous amuse le plus c'est
de voir les voitures qui ralentissent
certaines s'arrêtent regardent y en a
qui viennent jusque au portail e à la
verrière un jury passe évaluer les
décorations du 14 au 18 décembre
une maison un appartement et un magasin
se verront chacun décerner une
récompense mais le concours n'est pas
nécessaire pour certains cela permet
d'égayer une période délicate en
ravivant l'esprit de noël